salut tout le monde ici envergure et on
continue notre série de podcasts sur les
candidats offer speak tout simplement ni
plus ni moins après cetto m'bengue
rennes c'est au tour d'un autre grand
dans un style complètement différent le
joueur d'auburn jabbari smith il shoote
il shoote très très bien il est grand il
bouge bien aussi on va voir quelles sont
ses qualités on va voir là où il
pourrait atterrir les contexte favorable
ou non pour lui c'est le menu de ce
nouveau podcast nouvel épisode envergure
général
[Musique]
avec un an tu es alain guillou un
supporter de nantes à l'origine comment
vas tu vois ça va très bien je fais
parler de basket avec avec mes amis en
plus tu vois bien sûr
et en plus nantes est en train de gagner
je pas si le match était reine leur
haine de manu
savent à manu mais ça va on parle de
jeanne-marie de l'accord il a quand même
le sourire et enfin me from canada de
benoît lelièvre
comment vas tu
on va très bien on va parler jabbari
smit et c'est toi ben qui va nous conter
son histoire puisque c'est vous êtes
désormais habitués si vous suivez nos
podcasts aller sur notre site ils y sont
tous ou sur youtube ou sur votre
plateforme d'écouté on commence avec
l'histoire de la personne dont on va
parler plus tard puisque derrière le
prospect il y à un homme et donc jabbari
smith d'où vient-il ben c'est à toi
jabbari smith hill 18 ans il va avoir 19
ans vendredi prochain le 13 mai donc
c'est un très très jeunes joueurs dans
cette cuvée il vient de 110 quick un
jour j'ai parlé à deux tables rondes en
georgie tel à l'école samedi quick et ce
qui est important de savoir avec jabri
smid sait que c'est le fils de l'ancien
joueur nba jabbari smith qui était un
joueur au profil relativement similaires
il s'entraîne donc s'entraîne donc avec
son paternel depuis juin un très jeune
âge mais un truc intéressant pour lui
c'est qu'ils aient commencé à jouer au
basket
compétitif à l'âge de 14 ans seulement
en ce moment un os
au lycée donc ça va pas si longtemps que
ceux qui jouent
compétitivement donc quand même encore
une grande capacité de 2
d'amélioration sa courbe de progression
est encore au début je dirais est un
autre aspect vraiment très très
intéressant profonde ce jeune homme là
qui ressortit dans plusieurs dans
l'entrevue avec plusieurs personnes avec
qui j'ai parlé aussi qui je crois est
très favorable à son corps c'est que
c'est un freak de l'entraînement c'est
un jeune homme qui aime s'entraîner il
impose de jouer des matches de basket il
aime pas juste bien paraître il aime
beaucoup s'entraîner il aime aller au
zoo jim pareil cas o'byrne était là à 6
heures du matin à tous les jours
simplement parce qu'ils aiment
s'améliorer il aime prendre des lancers
donc ça pour un jeune homme de cette de
cette envergure là de cette grosse
horloge de cette taille là c'est très
très très important ses traits au bureau
très bien c'est un joueur qui avec un
excellent tir malgré sa grande taille
c'est quelque chose que son père avait
aussi c'est quelque chose que son père
tenait à ce qu'il aille c'est vraiment
c'est pour moi quelque chose sur quoi il
l'a fait travailler pendant toutes ces
années là donc
derrière cette technique qui est très
fluide qui est très simple il ya
énormément de travail et donc très jeune
mr bosseur avec un bon pedigree basque
très bien voilà le portrait dressé
tu parles d'un du fils de jah barry
smith et effectivement il s'appelle
jabari smith de saccades et non pas
juniors donc son père devait même être
junior si on suit la logique
manu parle-nous du physique de jabba
rice mise puisque ben addi tire bien
pour sa taille alors c'est qu'elle est
sa taille à quoi ils ressemblent pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais vu jouer le
bonhomme ou même pas en photo
c'est un job ariste fils est un grand
gaillard 2 2 m 0,8 pour cent kilos en
tout cas c'est les dernières mesures
qu'on a avec une envergure estime à
700 et 1 2 m 15
c'est immense il a c'est un joueur qu'à
une poussée de croissance sur ses années
lycée donc là sur notamment sur le donc
l'annoncé raid dessus de 0,8 sur les
fiba il était annoncé à 2,03 yade osant
donc cinq centimètres de plus
dc c'est énorme pour un joueur comme ça
qui apprend encore à jouer au basket
finalement le petit hic sur ce physique
c'est les roches hôtes sont donc sans de
gravité au donc un peu plus de
difficultés pour pour défendre sur les
joueurs plus petit que lui est plus
rapide que notamment mais même si l'aca
il a une très bonne fluidité c'est un
gars qui montrent assez vite au cercle
sans fioritures on sent pas qu'il est
gêné par part soit encore on ne sent pas
du tout ça donc ça super intéressant
c'est un peu plus compliqué balle en
main quand il doit dribbler ou là on
semble au contraire que c'est grandement
peuvent un peu le génie notamment sur
les crossover dribble entre les jambes
il est beaucoup plus lent d'un coup
parce qu'il n'arrive pas encore à
maîtriser ça il sait si lui il lui
manque encore falloir qu'ils apprennent
ça avec eux avec le staff nba savent api
va pouvoir exploser au cercle un peu
beaucoup plus facilement
alan pourquoi on en parle comme d'un
numéro un potentiel ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça par rapport aux autres
duos de la cuvée par rapport aux banques
héros par rapport aux tchèques même par
rapport à charge ils n'étaient pas vu
aussi aux avant le début de l'année mais
complètement c'était une course à trois
banques héros
aux migraines cunningham kumming à se re
classifie dans la case de l'année
dernière c'est un petit peu une place
déjà par elvis était vu comme un top 10
est en fait bas je pense qu'il a été
dans le meilleur un des murs pas le
meilleur contexte parce qu'il ya eu des
petits soucis mais un sac et o'byrne
pour le son jeu offensif et pour la mise
en avant du sont ses qualités tire sa
qualité ses qualités d' attaque ça a été
vraiment tout de suite quelque chose qui
a très bien marché 2 le match s'est tout
de suite bien fait on a vu un joueur
capable de mettre d'avoir de remous pour
remonter la balle avoir des libertés
pour prendre les décisions ballonnements
donc à ce fantasme du dribble chez lui
il a surtout vu un joueur capable de
tirer dans énormément de position et
donc ce qui attire problème billets
s'est passé a cassé le bras c'est la
capacité à mettre des tirs parce qu'en
fait qui pourra toujours tiré au dessus
de ses adversaires il fait quasiment
2010 donc cette capacité là elle est
tellement rare chez un joueur de sa
taille et de son âge qu'elle attire avec
en plus derrière le fantasme du dribble
potentiellement le fantasme de la
polyvalence défensive parce qu'on a vu
très active très capable de vraiment
extrêmement bien bougés par moments
défensivement donc il ya à la fois je
pense un des tâches est vraiment le tir
ne tire comme quelque chose de sûr il ya
des fantasmes à côté qui pourra en faire
un potentiel des mureaux voilà le débat
du jour et ce qui l'est le favori pour
vous pour être numéro 1 je vais vous
lancez manu et à l'année et ben sera
l'arbitré je sais que dans vos
classements je vous l'avais pas dans le
même tiers alan toi il est dans ton
deuxième tiers si je dis pas de bêtises
et manu toi tu la numéro un alors manu
je te laisse commencé pour quoi pour toi
il est au dessus du lot au dessus des
autres îles pour mahut étude du des
autres je le mets numéro un pour le
potentiel uniquement parce que je pense
j'espère qu'il va s'améliorer partout
sauf que dans ce partout il est déjà
très bon donc il le seul truc où il va
falloir qu'ils s'améliorent un peu plus
c'est au niveau du protection de cercle
cette année l'état complète kessler donc
ce n'était pas son rôle de dalles et
protéger le cerc entre guillemets sauf
qu'en nba c'est des banques la poste il
pourra avoir quatre ou cinq selon
quelle équipe fin de ce long avec qui
sera entouré il pourra jouer les deux je
pense à terme et ses jeux j'achète un
foot 40% à 3 points cette année sur plus
de cinq tentatives pour un mec 2d mais
disent quasiment 2010 c'est incroyable
j'achète une
diversité du tiers du pool up du 3
points du mi-distance du catch and shoot
pareil mi-distance et trois points il
s'est quasiment déjà tout faire en fait
et il peut encore s'améliorer c'est ça
le plus incroyable non le rachète tout
ça et j'espère qu'il va pouvoir à terme
protéger le cercle est encore plus forte
dans l'attaqué du cercle sur son sur
premier pas
et j'espère qu'il aura aussi un meilleur
dribbles qui potentiellement va l'aider
à gagner des minutes encore beaucoup
plus et être beaucoup plus rapide que
des joueurs plus grand que lui voire de
sa taille mais aussi à pouvoir illimité
d'émettre un peu plus petits comme les
ailiers ou les arrières sur des miss
match sur sur des soucis défensifs donc
j'achète sur tout le potentiel en fait
je vois un mec qui va savoir tout faire
pour fait et qui va faire booster une
sorte de carl anthony times
j'ai peur de dire des bêtises ouais
c'est pas fou c'est pas fou
non c'est le meilleur scénario fin passe
peut-être pas le meilleur scénario mais
serge ayoub sensible et encore sur le
tir en fait sur la diversité du tir je
pense qu'il a en plus de potentiel que
tendent mes jeux majeurs que le meilleur
show pig wayne shorter dos tout le temps
bah pour moi
et ça dépend comme on y suit le big ben
pour moi c'est en aidant en tout cas on
en tout cas on a la zone
d'excellence tu nous as bien imager la
zone d'excellence de vers laquelle tu
l'imaginait pouvoir évoluer dans les
années futures alan pour quoi pour toi
il est un petit tiers en dessous de chet
et banque héros qui sont au tiers 1
parce que moi je le vois plus comme le
finisseur d'action ultime je le vois moi
je crois moi en qualité d'initiation de
jabbari smith il ya plusieurs choses qui
me dérange un peu dans son jeu déjà son
manque d'agressivité vers le cercle
c'est à dire que c'est un joueur qui
fuit quasiment 2010 mais qui shootait
43% à 2 points l'an passé on va initier
pourquoi parce que ils preuve il prenait
beaucoup de cire contestées c'est mais
comme c'est un choc mais coeur enfin le
dire quasiment historique pour sa taille
son âge il ya toujours plus shooter au
dessus des adversaires mais je crois
moins que manu danseurs on apparaît
souvent lorsqu'on tousse et on m'a dit
tu sais il ya très longtemps qu'il
allait avoir j'aime varier on a eu ces
débats là moi je crois m'en audry pour
accéder au cercle et je le vois plus
comme le stretch foire dimitri schrive
qui va écarter le terrain et donc avec
le potentiel balle en main un peu moins
important que qu'un paolo guerrero
et je crois moi ça ça son influence
défensive que cetto m'bengue après il
est plus jeune que les deux vilains en
moins de moins que coach et amoureux
c'est pas c'est notable surtout à cet
âge là mais voilà je vois plus comme ce
finisseur d'action ultime se shooter ce
stretch fort moderne moi je le vois
comme la version la version sous
stéroïdes de rashard lewis en fait en
2000 en 2022 très tôt qu'il ya 48 ans
genre comme ça ok ok j'aime bien j'aime
bien des stéroïdes rachat
d'alico avait bien là qu'on perd mais
j'aime bien la comparaison à michael
pour le 30 juin à oui nous manque
peut-être un petit peu de dribbles mais
je crois qu'ils peuvent vraiment se
peut vraiment à s'améliorer sur ce côté
là quelque chose qui m'énerve aussi dans
son jeu je pense qui explique un peu son
sa pauvre
sap au moyen-âge deux points c'est
qu'ils aient besoin d'avoir les deux
pieds absolument plantées dans le sol
pour shooter il ya une excellente
mécanique de tir mais il doit être pas
son panier il doit avoir les deux pieds
plantés dans le sol
mais jusqu'à un certain son inefficacité
est aussi lié absolument que les trois
tard et avec lesquels il jouait à auburn
avait trois gars greene johnson pizza
sport je crois qu'ils s'appelaient qui
s'échangent et une neurones c'est que la
chute est absolument tout et lui refiler
le ballon avec deux secondes dans la
chaude club pour essayer de faire
arriver quelque chose sur l'inefficacité
aparté en partie en partie de ça disons
que le speed bages mais je le mets
troisième à détroit
suivi duncan gamme pour pour initier le
son efficacité avant monte vraiment
vraiment à gauche je suis un manu et
allende là-dessus je crois que c'est
peut-être pas initiateurs d'élite mais
je ne cracherais pas je ne donnerai pas
le dos à un potentiel évalué l'évolution
en initiateur nba c'est une question de
progression ce une question de 2
2 une question justement de courbe de
progression que je pense que l âge de
travailler
est ce que tu vois des blocages
physiologique ou ou
intellectuelles fin dans l'intelligence
de jeu je parle qui qui pourrait
le bloquer pour accéder à ce statut
d'initiateur
primaire qui ferait qui mériteraient ce
statut de numéro un
intellectuel non je crois qui est quand
même assez
bien éduqué sur le côté basket
physiquement parlant comme le disait
manu et longues jambes les l'ombre cas
ça va être très difficile de créer face
à une défense un billet qu'il prend 1,12
par exemple je crois je te manque qui va
être capable de faire arriver des choses
qu'on va être capable de matérialiser
des points là où s qui en a pas mais je
crois pas que peu voire pouvoir le faire
de manière constante jeu j'aime bien le
scénario d'alan je pense que
le potentiel
un étape au dessus
sur le sur le handle
manu est ce que est ce que tu vois là
aussi d'une évolution très haute et
comment comment le sait comment elle se
matérialisait ce que est ce que pour toi
c'est quelqu'un qui on va donner la
balle plus tôt elle beau comme on
faisait cette année à auburn ou
carrément à l'extérieur et là c'est un
vrai porteur de balle balle à tous les
porteurs de balle qu'on voit en playoffs
aujourd'hui quoi bein je ne vois pas
peint dans l'initiation moi j'entends
quelqu'un qui est capable de créer pour
les autres et ça pour moi c'est moi ça
va pas être son rôle en fait je lui
demande pas d'être mineur sais pas ce
que je lui demande donc là en termes
d'initiation j'attends surtout sur lui
sur lui-même sur son tir est ce qu'il va
être capable de créer un peu d espace
esquiva capable d'aller prendre de la
vitesse vers le haut comme il le fait
bien mais j'attends que cette fin
j'estime qui peut être encore meilleur
là dessus en fait et il ya eu plein de
petits trucs comme ça sur vraiment sur
le tir à mi distance où il force
beaucoup des fois alors qu'ils n'avaient
pas besoin de faire ça il y avait des
passes possibles soit allèles soit
peut-être de racket mais il préféra
shooter avec deux défenseurs sur lui
donc classer de l'intelligence et la
vision c'est c'est plein de choses mais
qui vont arriver je pense assez
rapidement via le travailler avec un
staff via le space singh via le terrain
y est plus grand
il en fait il veut ça va être step by
step c'est un garçon qui fait du basket
comme depuis très peu encore qu'il
apprend à jouer un faux compte comme
tous les gamins de son âge donc moi je
pense que ça va être step by step et il
va réussir mais dans l'initiation encore
une fois moi je joue je lui donne pas la
balle en fait c'est pas ça que je lui
demande d'aller scorer près du cercle
est loin du cercle c'est un finisseur
comme dit alan cinq mois j'attends mais
ça je l'attend pas qu'il fasse du au
kitsch pas toi tu es d'accord mais c'est
juste que ce genre de rôle là tu es prêt
à le draft et premier parce que tu
estimes que les autres vont pas
forcément faire mieux ouais et puis
encore il faudra une salle potentiel en
fait il peut être super bon partout
alors qu'un au contraire d'un chèque
fond qui va être bon partout mais je
trouve un potentiel plus haut que switch
est en fait le la le ch est actuelle est
meilleure qu'à quel joueur actuel est
meilleur que jabari mais à terme pour
moi jabbari a plus de potentiel sur plus
de choses qui s'est déjà très bien faire
alors que fait c'est un peu plus
shooteur un peu plus
elijah wood bloqueurs on sait déjà ce
qu'il va faire cher
alors et ici on va chez lapointe de manu
un autre truc qui est un point qui rend
l'évaluation que plus difficile c'est
que c'est probablement des trois joueurs
qui sont au top 3 packs héros chat et
vite
c'est lui avec le plancher le plus haut
c'est lui qui a le moins de chances de
flopper je crois au niveau professionnel
parce qu'il va se rendre utile
absolument n'importe quelle équipe ce
qui est très très très en demande et 1
incorporé à le traiter à 13 en amendes
il faut pour pouvoir devenir
potentiellement cette licorne qui je
louche ou des trois qui défend la no
donc je crois que c'est sont un peu qui
qui qui qui qui fonce le jugement moi je
les douzièmes personnellement derrière
chat mais c'est vraiment ce que je crois
que c'est lui qui a la chance d'abriter
des droits
ok c'est intéressant aussi
juste pour donner des petits chiffres
contextuel
on disait tout à l'heure qu'ils allaient
peu au cert seulement soixante trois
tentatives à -2 je crois que c'est à
moins de 60 centimètres du cercle et les
mesures soixante trois tentatives donc
au moins deux par match ou deux par
match à peu près ces faibles pour un
joueur évidemment de cette taille-là
contre bath en 62 tentatives ce qu'on
appelle les longs de points mais sur
lesquels il a une bonne réussite non
pardon sur lesquels il ya une réussite
moyenne à 30 6% ce qui est bien mais ce
n'est pas ce qui est pas fou mais par
rapport à la quantité à la difficulté
pas renoncé c'est c'est correct et 42% à
3 points sur dit en tête + 10 tentatives
par centre possession c'est également
très très élevé c'est quasiment du
jamais vu pour un joueur de cette taille
là depuis kevin durant et j'ai plus les
chiffres en tête de kevin durant mais en
gros c'est c'est
assez historique comme tu disais alan
homme parlant de sa défense on avait
l'idée d'un protecteur de certes
peut-être mais le contexte o'byrne
c'était on l'a dit walker kessler pour
expliquer walker kessler c'était le
meilleur protecteur de cercles de la nba
cette saison en terme de pourcentage de
tirs contrés et même de réussite des
adversaires autour du cercle quand il
était là à l'âne qui ils défendent main
jabbari et qui il défend à terme en nba
dans quel rôle
je pense que demain on sait là où c'est
tout c'est un peu être que lui et de
chute pour mon devoir demander qu'ils
défendent mais parce que
aussi tellement bien ils sont capables
d'être mise sur un terrain avec
quelqu'un qui peut défendre la no dès
demain une bille et donc on lui
demandera pas potentiellement ils
défendent dano lui demandera je pense de
fer du second rideau un peu en tour de
contrôle il ne disait il un très bon qi
basket face à soi il anticipe bien et il
se retrouve très actif il a les mains
extrêmement extrêmement active il est
très bon sur les renversements il y bien
les jeux à venir dont je pense qu'on
peut lui demander de défendre les allées
poste 3-4 ça va être compliqué sur
situation de switch parce que donc s'il
ya une bonne mobilité c'est durant une
diète défend des meilleurs ailiers du
monde physiquement et tout ça mais je
pense qu'on va avoir un joueur qui
sur les trois quatre premières années
nous biette 1 1 2e
protecteur de série au top protecteur de
cirque secondaire tous les fantasmes
réside sur la sa qualité à devenir ce
protecteur de cercle primaire ce qui est
devenu shérif joe jackson cette année du
côté de memphis alors que c'était pas
c'était vraiment pas gagner parce que
les fans c'est un peu le fantasme est
propre pas parlé avec des fans comme une
fille sur les premières années c'était
qu'il était incapable de jouer sans
valenciunas par exemple à l'époque
c'était pas possible et il est devenu et
c'est pour ça que memphis après cette
envolée si on compare ce qu'elle pense
que djediat barry smith peut devenir
protecteur de serre primaires comme manu
je pense qu'on peut le draft est numéro
1 moi j'ai un peu plus de réserve parce
que je crois que moi sa verticalité mais
si dans cinq ans il peut être protecteur
de cette primaire alors là il est il et
il est l'étalon donc c'est tout le monde
roule
c'est effectivement là autour nos débats
et quand même on va parler de sentir
puisque toute allure et puis tout à
l'heure on dit peu il peut shooter
n'importe comment et c'est ben est ce
que tu peux un peu un peu de détails et
ça
quelle variété il a dans son tir tu as
déjà relevé une limite en disant il faut
qu'il ait les deux pieds plantés
dans quels différents contextes on l'a
vu cette année et ce qu'il a des shoots
des moves qui pourra avoir premier jour
en nba ça va être son gagne-pain quoi
quand rien ne marchera il aura sa
son pain et son beurre c'est le poulpe
j'ai rarement vu quelqu'un jeune joueur
à avoir des pôles up en transition comme
ça surtout à sa taille il est capable de
mener trois points transition c'est
magnifique il est capable de créer à
partir de sons de son dribble mais de
manière très très très très basique là
c'est très c'est comme on dit au québec
ces steaks de l'état une patate c'est
ses traits
[Musique]
ces deux bases jeudi il ya quelqu'un
mouche de dribbles qui fait pencher vers
l'avant pour se créer un peu d'espoir il
est capable de mettre à sortir il eu
quelques fait de jouer
à deux points des albums et moi je suis
vraiment pas qu'on véhicule sont sur ses
appuis sont pas là du tout lorsqu'il est
fait des fois ça rentre parce que
justement la mécanique qu un pauvre côté
- opel mais tu vas lui mais tu vois le m
contre un grand toit lienz nba ou
contrat d'horreur de la vie parce qu'à
moi c'est sur le cul donc ça il va avoir
besoin de gagner du
johnny se retrouve sur le qu'une donc
ouais resté sur le cul vous dernier si
ces procédés que federer six mètres mais
mais ouais c'est vraiment
ces chaudes ses shoots lac qui sont sur
moi dans son nationale présentement je
n'ai pas beaucoup vu chuter
dans catch and shoot shoot est en
mouvement shooter en sortie d'écran j'ai
pas beaucoup cette année alors ce qu'il
est un peu là d'urgence à auburn
peut-être qui les a dans dans son
arsenal ici les eaux tant mieux si les
autant mieux ça fait juste de lui un
prospect avec + plus de valeur
meneur digne de ce nom en nba et 1,8
halliburton
john green un quai de canet gamme
ça va juste prof de données
manu quel contexte idéal tu vois
justement pour lui au début qu'elle
avec quel autre intérieur il peut être
enfin avec quel type de joueur il peut
faire la paire avec quelle quel profil à
la mène plutôt quelqu'un qui va qui va
être distributeurs plutôt quelqu'un qui
va être slasher voilà comment comment tu
vois les choses en intérieur moi je le
vois plus avec un
cinq de base qui va être fort proche du
panier en attaque et que ce qui va lui
permettre plus de s'écarter
et tir à trois points et en défense moi
je le vois défendre sur trois quatre
cinq à terme est vraiment à terme
donc mais au tout début je pense qu'il
faut le lac ou l'accompagner avec un
quelqu'un qui veut protéger le cercle
pour justement crient ils suivent un peu
c'est paris qui lui apprennent justement
à prendre sa place petit à petit
mais ans après en terme d' équipe je
sais pas trop où je le verrai en fait ne
sais pas trop de l'ag le top 20 g la
loterie sous les yeux et j'ai pas une
équipe où je me dis tiens là il fit fitr
est
peut-être les heures il n'y a pas yaya
toure kitsch et élus la rhd et arda
ouais mais je suis même pas convaincu en
fait
bon avec nour kitsch et l'île heard
c'est une belle base pour commencer en
nba ouais voilà c'est différent symmes
ne jugeait pas une équipe faudrait que
les blazers et de la chance à la loterie
puisque
enfin faudrait qu'ils aient de la chance
et qui piquent probablement top 3
alan est ce que tu peux me parler un peu
de
des scénarios qui pourraient ne pas
fonctionner ben disait y en a peu ben
disait y en a peu parce que
il a justement son gagne pain etc est ce
qu'il ya un monde dans lequel ça et ça
fonctionne pas quoi il ya un monde dans
lequel ça fonctionne pas si on le drop
iii et qu'il est juste un stratfor en
fait il devient qu'il ne travaille
jamais ce dribble pour accéder au cercle
donc pour se faciliter la vie en groupe
parce que il faut quand même pour être
premier au deuxième l'option d'une
équipe qui joue le titre secret des
paniers faciles à l'est sur inzaghi
guerre n'était capable cette année
d'aller sur la ligne franchement il à
votre équipe ou very moi j'avais des
petits soucis sur la prison de manque de
verticalité et en donne un peu un peu
fou pour le moment en fait on si un
équipe draft il au draft up 3 et kylie
qui est simplement à stratfor dont on
tire mais qu'avec moins de polyvalence
défensive et et ça c'est je pense que
l'équipe sera déçu il est d'ailleurs
s'il deviendra charles et russes en fait
moi ça me dérange pas rashard lewis
était un excellent joueur et surtout en
2022 ce genre de jour là était déjà
capable de mettre des cartons à l'époque
s'y attendait pas encore hollande donc
en fait s'il il faut et qui ce qu'il
soit karam déjà amélioré son deuil parce
que comme il va se faire clause out
super fort à cause du tir ça pourra
vraiment ouvrir son jeu car de poser un
dribble et ensuite bas accéder au cr
tout poulet pas mes distances ou prendre
une décision parce que on a on a la
qualité de passe et les parts incroyable
mais il c'est un bon passeur franchement
sur les lieux à vélo j'ai trouvé qu'il
était intéressant il était capable
d'avoir une des bonnes rotations prendre
des décisions donc ça en fait je pense
que tout pas un petit peu du dribble et
de la verticalité s'il améliore ça il
deviendra plus que des simples stress
forme et si ça stagne un peu il sera
juste peut-être ce quatrième cinquième
homme d'une équipe qui joue le titre et
peut-être que tu doives ça dans le top 3
pas sûr
j'entends bene scutin tu as des choses à
ajouter sur ce côté le mental latitude
et c'est sur le terrain on a déjà parlé
mais tu sais que c'est quelque chose
qu'on qu'on aime bien un peu développés
est ce que tu as des choses en plus à
dire au delà du fait qu'il soit le fils
donc de jabbari smit
qui vit qui est en soi il ya quatre ans
il est très émotif et prend surtout en
défense prince et ses devoirs défensifs
très très au sérieux et même qu'un qui
s'est il fait pas un jeu spectaculaire
et pas juste faire une sorte provoque
une sortie de balle ou quelque chose
comme ça on le voit est très très être
un catalyseur émotionnelle pour son
équipe je crois que s'il ya une plus
value
je sois moi je crois que justement je
pense pas que c'est un jeu le genre de
joueur qui va se contenter d'être un
strap joueur qui va se contenter des
tricheurs luis ce qui pourrait poser
problème dans certaines équipes qui vont
qui leur demande et qu'ils dorment andré
que ça dans le fond je crois que si on
lui demande que de faire ça il va se
mettre à prendre des décisions par
lui-même va se mettre à dribbler par
lui-même et c'est là qu'ils vont peut
être y avoir un danger de postes parce
qu'on veut le vin bio ben
je regarde orlando
je regarde orlando qui est comme pas de
structure encore à leur façon de jouer
qu'ils ont un peu refrain designer dans
ce rôle of fait que c'est un peu ce que
je veux dire est ce quelqu'un qui ont eu
le désir de réussir vraiment vraiment
très très fort donc je crois justement
que 6e il se veut un peu de la
politicaillerie de la désorganisation ça
risque peut-être de mal se passer
peut-être besoin d'un bon contexte plus
qu'un chat par exemple qui a l'air un
peu plus dans sa bulle quoi et puis
surtout avec un sénat réunis peuvent pas
être mais
mais encore là comme je dis il ya les
skieuses pour remplir ses missions et
qui s'ouvre est raffiné pour tous d'un
top 10 c'est ce qu'ont voulu donner des
chances de se prouver moi je pense que
je regarde je re lucau qui ici qui ont
le quatrième pays qu'ils ont qui bouge
au numéro deux
avec un chat et avec un guide et qui
peuvent jouer avec ou sans la balle
moi je trouve que le mec c'est
intéressant
effectivement effectivement
manu est ce que tu as tu as d'autres
choses a ajouté qu'on a qu'on n'a pas
peut-être sur la mentalité j'étais pas
je n'ai pas entendu là-dessus mais ou
sur d'autres points techniques qu'on n'a
pas évoqué non mais qui très complet
alan
nan franchement mais je souhaitais
vraiment un plaisir de le voir jouer
cette année quoi aurait initié
franchement il était
incroyable dès le début de l'année est
ce que c'était un bon contexte où un
mauvais combat en fait c'est ça moi je
me suis dit c'est un super contexte
parce qu'on a vu depuis deux trois ans
o'byrne a quand même pu mettre en avant
des joueurs vraiment bien
au cours aux torts même s'il s'est fait
un peu saoul draft et j'arrive cooper
aussi la une avant ils vont à la march
madness sous mao khê qui a été très très
bon aussi au kiki et moi et c'est fait
drafté est en fait je me suis dit c'est
un super contexte parce qu'on va lui ont
valu je trouve que steve earle donc
bruce peur le pardon le coach il laisse
vraiment
liberté à ses joueurs en fait il essaie
vraiment de liberté à ses joueurs alors
il leur crie beaucoup dessus mais il
leur laisse beaucoup de liberté dans la
prise de décision est en fait plus et
comme le disait ben plus l'année passée
plus j'ai vu que l'on fait le garde
plaît donc de nouveau des extérieurs
étaient était vraiment pas bon et je
n'ai pas prévu ça je sais donc pour un
intérieur pour son jeu et poser sur le
tir et qui même si il ya des fantasmes
de la création personnelle du tir il n'y
a pas besoin d'être placé sur pick'n pop
d'être bien servi et surtout d'être
servi parce que moi j'ai refait le match
de la march madness spock miami il est
même pas trop servi en fait pendant
c'est qu'ils aient dit johnson et les
odeurs comme nietzsche ou beaucoup en
première intention donc en fait non
c'était pas un si bon compte est ce que
ça il n'aurait pu avoir mais
qui dit johnson n'a 3,50 à la raclette
la
baillie effectivement ils perdent très
tôt à la march madness et jabbari smith
ne fait pas un gros match mais il n'a
pas beaucoup de tirs mais l'effectif
de miami qu'avec des gens devant de
quatre ans ici je vais rentrer dedans
tout
oui c'est vrai dont ils iront qui va la
draft enfin qui fait pas plus de 24 ans
de transport iceberg c'est pas si mal et
plus ils vivent
et charlène humour ton ami c'est ça
voilà charlie moore futur mvp de la
ligue allemande
c'est sûr
messieurs merci beaucoup c'était tout
pour jabbari smith le deuxième
qui sera donc raft est très très très
très probablement dans le top 5 voire
top 3 voir donc top 1 c'était notre
question on vous invite à partager 11,1
vitalic et on vous invite à vous abonner
on vous invite à aller voir sa fiche sur
envergure point c'est on vous donne
rendez-vous
pour nos lives qui qui continue fin qui
vont commencer puis continue je sais pas
trop comment on va sortir ce podcast
19 21 23 25 mai à 21h à chaque fois avec
à chaque fois une franchise le focus sur
une franchise du top 8 avec des invités
spéciaux et avec vous dans le chatt vos
questions évidemment pour y répondre on
sera là et on analysera on creusera un
petit peu plus les contextes nba pour
chacun des joueurs d'autant plus qu'en
ce moment il ya les playoffs et que
c'est toujours intéressant d'observer
les dynamiques et les rôles qu'ils y
brille ben manu alan chao
et bisous tout le monde